welcome to academy dialogues it starts
with us my name is sean finney
we are continuing our series of
conversations about race ethnicity
history opportunity in the art of
filmmaking
hosted by the academy today's topic
is owning our stories we're incredibly
honored to have bird running water
director of sundance institute's
indigenous programs
moderating our conversation today
joining byrd our screenwriter nissan
sagai
writer director actor elemaya tell
feathers
writer producer lejia villalobos and
writer
director producer lulu wong here's a
little background on each of our
speakers
as director of the sundance institute's
indigenous programs bird oversees the
sundance native filmmakers lab
the native producers fellowship and the
festival's native form
a native of the cheyenne and moscalero
apache tribes
bird has been with sundance for the last
10 years supporting the buildup of a
global indigenous film community
he is skilled in leading panel
discussions and workshops around the
world and has worked with
major institutions including the ford
and rockefeller foundations
he holds degrees in journalism public
affairs and native studies
in fact he was the first graduate of the
native american studies program at the
university of oklahoma
nissan is a native of nigeria who was
raised in england and amazingly had a
career as an emergency room doctor
before becoming a screenwriter
she wrote the script for the 2013 movie
bell
about the daughter of an enslaved
african woman in a british admiral set
in 1700s british society
her credits also include the teleplay
for the oprah winfrey produced movie
their eyes were watching god and
co-writer for the six part series
gorilla starring idris elba and produced
by john ridley the writer of 12 years a
slave
ella maya tell feathers is a rising
filmmaker who is bringing compelling
authentic stories about indigenous
people to the screen
she comes from sami the indigenous
territory of the sami people in northern
europe
she is also part of the kanai first
nation blackfoot confederacy
her films include the multi-awarded
documentary short rebel
which is autobiographical and the
feature the body remembers when the
world broke open
which she co-wrote co-directed and acted
in
it premiered in 2019 at the toronto film
festival receiving three awards
including
best picture and at the berlin film
festival
lijia villalobos has had a long career
as both studio executive
and a filmmaker her many film credits
include writing and executive producing
the independent feature
la mismaluna also known as under the
same moon
writing the film firelight produced by
alicia keys and mary martin
and consulting on pixar animated
features including coco
firelight was nominated for an naacp
image award and received a 2013
humanitas prize
lulu wong first gained international
attention for writing and directing
posthumous in 2014
and then again in 2019 for her second
feature
the farewell which she wrote directed
and co-produced
the farewell follows struggling new york
city artist billy played by aquafina
who travels to china to visit her dying
grandmother wong filmed the farewell in
the neighborhood where her own
grandmother actually lived
and she cast her great aunt liu hung as
herself in the film
last year variety named wong one of 10
directors to watch and aquafina won a
golden globe for her performance
the farewell also won the independent
spirit award for best film
we look forward to hearing your
conversation everyone bird take it away
thank you and i want to thank everyone
for joining us especially our filmmakers
our screenwriters you know
it's i feel so honored to be um here
having a conversation with you
i myself am just kind of logging in
essentially from
uh gabriela no tongva lands and tatavium
lands which hollywood is built upon
i don't think that's a fact that's very
well known within many communities uh
but it's very i'm very honored to come
here to you today but i also have to
mention that
i myself you know descend from
matrilineal and matriarchal indigenous
nations and so i feel very humbled
myself to be speaking with
such four powerful women such as
yourselves and i think the great voices
that you
you bring to your work and to our
screens and to
audiences around the world so i just
want to first of all say thank you for
what you give and what you do i wanted
to you know just basically kind of start
our conversation by
i guess kind of asking you um i think as
a point of view
on our conversation like i wonder if
somebody could kick us off just by
telling us how they would kind of
describe
what they've defined as their own
authentic voice that they're lending to
their work does somebody want to kick us
off with that
lulu do you want to start um sure
yeah i think it you know it took me a
really long time i think i'm still
in the process of discovery of what that
means to
to have a voice and to
have a voice in your work uh so for me
for a long time it was finding um
the juxtaposition of pathos and humor
which for me is very much at the
heart of my family my
culture the way that i see the world the
way that my family has taught me to see
the world
so humor was a big part of um
like finding you know the kind of humor
in my work that i wanted to
show was a big part of my process of um
you know of it landing because you know
humor is so specific
to every culture and it may not be
easily translatable
so that was a really difficult thing
when i set out especially to make the
farewell to say oh this is funny and if
someone goes
well is it funny you know and how do you
like
break that down right um because what
someone finds funny
it just is and so that was
a big um exploration
of uh this particular type of humor and
especially with a visual medium like
film like for me it was
really a journey to figure out how to
actually represent that kind of humor
on screen so that it translates to
not only like to audiences but through
multiple different cultures
that's great thank you what about you
i think for me the thing that i always
have to keep going back and forth
about is how i see myself on the inside
which is a hundred percent mexican
and how i need to see myself in the
entertainment industry
which is as a latina
and you know for me a latina
the word latino or latinos and now
latinx for example
it's not really a word that we ever use
in the countries that we come from
you know we never say we're latinos we
always say we're mexican or we're
argentinian or we're colombian or we're
brazilian you know
but in hollywood because we have so
little power
and because our stories are seen
so rarely a little bit more in
television now but
almost non-existent in film
unless the movie is coming from another
country so i'm talking about
the ability for us who live in this
country to be able to tell our stories
that is almost non-existent in this
country
the only way that we can sort of have
um some kind of power is by uniting
with the word latina
or latinx or latino but for
me i will always be a mexican
that's how i see myself that is my heart
and so it's navigating that back and
forth and finding specificity
so that we don't just see a
latinx character in television and film
but that we actually bring in the
specificity
of what that character may bring based
on where they came from
or you know what their heritage is
right thank you for that nissan what
about you
um i think my i mean what i've always
wanted is to really expand what it means
to be black
on screen that um i found very
uh early on that um we were
you know as a black writer i was only
really allowed to
um inhabit quite
you know small spaces that there was a
lane that i was allowed to be in
um which didn't which was about the the
you know you look at the kinds of
stories
that i would be allowed to tell and the
kind of stories that black people would
be allowed to
appear in and um and i was very often
told
uh when i was uh developing bell for
example they would say
oh um this just doesn't feel like a
black story
because it's it's not for example urban
enough that uh it's not
uh um or there would be a
uh you know a real
focus on on black pain
to the point that it almost becomes the
you know you you say
you know what you're actually trying to
say
so i think it's to expand the kinds of
stories
we are allowed to tell and stories that
reflect the
entirety of who we are as as a people
and as a race and as as and um
to expand as well what what what people
would expect
to see when they look at a a film with a
black person
and not be defined by the stories
that uh people who you know for whatever
reason
those are the stories they feel
comfortable for us to be in that we need
to
in the same way as in the greater
society we need to expand the spaces
where
people would expect to see us and not
be uncomfortable we need to have that
on screen as well and that has been my
my uh quest in um defining myself as a
storyteller
is to be able to tell my story and not
the story you expect
me to tell right
thank you for that and you maya how
would you define your voice
um well i think as an indigenous
filmmaker someone who's black foot and
sami it's
always about centering myself and my
community
and being responsible and accountable to
my own community first and foremost and
thinking about
my own people as as as my audience
um to to speak about that idea of
expanding
the types of stories that can be told um
i think it's about uh thinking about the
way that indigenous people have been
represented on screen since
since you know film first started
rolling um it's it's been
decades and decades of misrepresentation
um and of outsiders telling our stories
so for me it's about always centering
myself
within my within my communities as an
indigenous person
and and centering indigenous people as
my audience
and and then i work from there well i
think you might be being a little modest
when you're saying
decades of misrepresentation i think it
might be more like a century perhaps
yeah
um ten decades let's say that uh but but
i think i think all of us coming from
the distinct communities that we're all
coming from
um you know i think we all have we all
share that in common you know we all
have that history of misrepresentation
of our own peoples that i think
definitely affects i think our movement
our
our attempts to move within a particular
industry and within
you know a world that i think kind of
has preconceived notions
of us um you know me son i i i heard you
say it
in one of your lectures that you said
the word diversity
is is complicated because in order for
there to be diversity
you know you have to acknowledge kind of
what the actual point of view
is you know and i think the history how
would you describe the historical point
of view that i guess were
challenging um that
i think the point of view that normality
is
white male uh
heterosexual um and um that their
stories are inherently interesting
and that um that there needs to be no
justification you just have to be
and your story is interesting and um
whereas uh to convince people that
uh that then you know i then have to be
diverse from that and once you
say that you're immediately saying that
that is normal
and my stories are not and some
accommodation has to be made
in order to tell my story and you can
end up that
telling my story is like castor oil you
know it's good for you you got to do it
but actually it's not what you really
it's not it's not pleasant it's not
the norm and i think we need to get away
from that that
um
the white male that i've discussed at
the beginning and nothing against it but
the white
it is diverse to me so they shouldn't
so i'm not exactly they are diverse to
me and
um the the feeling that those stories
are somehow
inherently interesting and our stories
have to be justified
um that is what i feel very strongly
against because to me a lot of those
stories
are specifically not interesting it
depends where you stand before you find
something interesting
and um i i'm worried about the use of
the word diversity because it entrenches
a particular point of view
that if that that is where we are
looking from
and that all the rest of us are diverse
i i i worry about that as a concept
although my son i have to say i was
recently putting together
a writer's room and i said you know
maybe we should get a white male in here
in order to have diversity because
right now we have only women and women
of color
and you know we're not gonna and
everyone said you know we don't need
that point of view everyone knows that
point of view plenty fine so
we ended up not doing it i love that
well i do believe that one of the things
you know we are commenting on is kind of
like you know who determines the frame
who determines what's centered who
determines the norm but i think that one
of the things we often don't
while we don't acknowledge that enough i
think also one of the things that
it definitely leads to is you know the
is creating bias
you know it creates by historical bias
against
you know all of us you know who are you
know not represented in that norm or
maybe misrepresented to that norm
but i just wondered if anyone had any
ideas about
how what are some steps we can take to
overcome that bias
because i think we do see it you know
it's in a it's
continually perpetuated
well i would say one is education
i think that um
like one thing that i always say and i
work much more in television than i
i work in features so i hope it's okay
to talk a little bit about that
experience in terms of feature
but you know one of the things that i i
say and i'm in the
equity and inclusion committee for the
writers guild of america
um and we have dealt with a lot of
issues of not just sexual harassment by
but harassment and um
racism in the writers rooms and you know
one thing that i always say
is writers who get a show
for the most part are being hired
because they are
talented writers they are incredible
storytellers
they are not getting hired because they
have leadership
skills but they are put in positions
where they have to be leaders of not
only the writer's room
but an entire crew and
a whole group of actors and nobody has
given them
any kind of information or classes
or leadership seminars of
how do you run a crew of 300 people
what is acceptable behavior and not
what is considered racist or not
who can help you navigate
these worlds and these stories and these
people and so now more than ever i think
it's super important because we no
longer just have
four networks with 30 shows being put on
the air every year
we have dozens of cable networks and
streaming services
in addition to network television
we have 500 shows in production a year
so we have a whole generation of writers
that are being put
in these positions with absolutely
no knowledge of how to lead and so a lot
of the issues that i think we
see also in feature sets by the way
because it's not like directors are
giving leadership skills
either but more so i think in television
because there's just so many shows that
are being produced a year
that i think it's vital to
as part of getting hired that you are
actually receiving
information and training on on these
issues
as well as just leadership you know
uh some leadership skills that can guide
you through a process of running a room
and beyond
yeah i think that's important i i agree
with the issue of training because i
one of the things about i think alimaya
has a really interesting story
of when she was you know co-directing
her first feature you know
she did did a particular level of
training
with with her crew and with i think with
actors and with communities and
everybody who was really involved in
in the creation and the production of
her feature film can you describe that
a bit much because it was a it was more
like around what you would call i guess
you said
cultural competency is that correct yeah
so
who is behind the camera absolutely
shapes the narrative
um and and within the indigenous film
community we have
quite a few really talented writers and
directors and producers
but we don't have enough people working
in the technical
uh departments we don't have enough
people working as sound recorders
editors all of those things
um and who makes up a crew absolutely
influences
uh influences the story that you're
telling um
and so as an indigenous filmmaker i
thought it was so crucial
that we hire as many indigenous people
within our crew especially in those key
technical positions
but what we're recognizing is that there
aren't enough of us to be working on
on on all the films that are being made
right now um and so
we took a two-fold approach one was that
you know we recognized that we had to
hire a lot of non-indigenous crew
members who were
lovely people um but there's a lot of
work to do in terms of
unlearning uh colonialism on learning
unlearning this complicated narrative
that we're all sitting in
and finding new ways of moving forward
so what we did was we
held a mandatory cultural competency
training and indigenous history
uh training for entire crew uh before we
went into production
which in a way was to sort of ground
everybody in a place of respect and
understanding that we have a lot of work
to do together
and then the second thing that we did
was that we hired
11 indigenous youth young people wanting
to work in film and all of the key
technical
departments in order to build capacity
in order to move forward and to
understand that
um one key way of dismantling these
these systems of
of oppression and systems of power um
that that that really shape the kinds of
stories that are being told on screen is
to
um is to build capacity within the
indigenous film community
itself thank you i think that's such an
interesting model to contemplate i think
because
if we continue to we have to acknowledge
i think in this moment in time you know
i think given our pandemic and given you
know the state-sponsored terrorism
that's happening against black people in
our country
you know it's like they're starting to
recognize you know these systems of
power and white supremacy that exist not
only in our
political systems in our country but i
definitely think that exists within our
industry
um and i think you know and if we're
gonna if we're gonna continue to
you know have an impact and to create
change i think those systems need to be
you know questioned more and that
they're in that people need to be
trained more lulu um you were just
talking about you know uh having staffed
a writer's room
can you describe kind of like how how we
all
should be getting into the room like how
did you get into the room in order to
get to this point where you are
um i mean honestly i've never written
um in a room before so i i
was told by a couple of my writers they
said
you know this is unlike any room i've
ever experienced and i think
in some ways because i didn't experience
the hierarchy and sort of um
the abuse that's so common in writer's
rooms
um i didn't know to bring i said you
know we're a team
here's a group of people who have very
different backgrounds
very bit different experiences um
who are all tremendously talented so why
wouldn't we
just talk about everything you know i
had to actually
teach um some of the writers who have
been in a lot of rooms and rooms where
they're not allowed to speak up
um they would like you know one woman
kept raising her hand i was like why are
you raising your hand just talk you know
um and so it is so strange to kind of
realize like here i am the showrunner
and i don't have
experience in a room so i would often
turn to her
and say you know having been in rooms
how is this normally done
um and then in other ways it was just
organic
it's just like you know you learn to be
friends you ask each other
for their um perspective and it
always made the story better always
right like
i think when people are fearful and they
don't give their perspective
that's not helping the show that's gonna
hurt
me and the show if someone says you know
actually
i have the same background as this
character this is not how we would say
things
i'm like please please please tell me
you know like do you want to take a look
at it you want to take a pass like
you know like call your father what
would he say like all of those things
are
what make the story rich and authentic
so i don't know why any show runner
would
ever want to keep people from you know
expressing that like that's just purely
ego and it's stupidity
i agree um you have a you came from
a background of being i believe a doctor
and was it were you a surgeon
as well yeah yeah political care
emergency room oh critical care
before you became a screenwriter what
was i mean what was that
path like i think i mean ultimately
getting to you know have your feature
films produced and made and
and shared and that there obviously was
a journey there and you had to get into
the
into those decision-making rooms like
how did you do that
well i um how i came into screenwriting
actually um
dovetails very very well with this uh
conversation we're having today
i i went to the cinema and i watched a
film
um and it was a film about
slavery and um
there were no black people in it it was
one of these
stories where we knew slavery was
appalling and terrible because the
wife of the the white wife of the white
male character she kept having her
her dinner parties disrupted by his
zeal to end slavery and i just didn't
see any black people and i suddenly
and i felt that i never saw myself
that if if if cinema is really it's like
the home movie of the world isn't it
really it's where we go and we see
ourselves and we're not there
and when we are there we're horribly
misrepresented
and um that you don't know you sit there
sort of balancing between the thrill of
seeing yourself
and and the embarrassment of how you're
portrayed
you know and uh and we just i just got
to the point where i thought
if and you know i just wanted to see
something that i would want to see i
wanted to see myself and i wrote a
screenplay
um it may seem sort of rather an odd
thing to do but as a doctor obviously
you
you tell stories all day so it was it
isn't as far a journey
but it was a desperate yearning need
to see uh myself uh represented
on screen in a way that i recognized and
i think that um that many of us feel
that that
it's like looking at you know it's like
being a member of a family i've said
this before
and you're watching the home movies of
the family and you're not there
you're not there you've been excluded
and you go why
and so that was why that was how i i
started and that was the beginning of my
journey
um to to to write and i i
imagine you had to deal with many
gatekeepers which is actually meant to
be the you know the thrust of our
discussion today you know
um because i think we we recognize that
our there that there are decision makers
you know there are there are gatekeepers
there are there are the ones who are
kind of you know who make the decisions
to i guess allow
some of us in uh likia what has been
your experience
in in navigating the the gatekeeping
i guess of the industry well you know i
i also didn't start as a writer i
actually started as an executive
so i was an executive in television and
i was also an executive in
features i worked within a studio system
and i also worked within a network
system
and in every case i was the only latina
and sometimes i was the only latina on
the entire floor
not just even in my apartment but the
entire floor
and so i always felt i had a
responsibility
in those positions to make sure
that the shows that i was overseeing or
you know the the movies that i may be
doing
um had representation which was which
wasn't the case so
i understand it from that side and i
and i understand the importance of
having
executives of color and producers of
color
in those positions that might help us
get through the door right because i
have been that person
um at the same time i think that
a lot of what could help is for for for
networks and for studios to actually
have a mandate
and i know they hate that word and i
know that they hate using that because
they feel like no we just need to allow
the filmmaker to be able to tell the
stories that they want to tell
and work in their creative environment
or whatever and i and i'm all for that
but i think that a lot of this has to
come from the top
they have to understand that we are
so far behind where we need to be
in terms of what the studios and
networks are representing in television
and what the world actually looks like
that unless they really start mandating
certain things
i'm not sure things are gonna change
drastically
so i but for me i just
feel like i try to tell the best stories
that i can
one way that i have been able to
navigate this
is that i never set out to only be
a network writer or i never set out to
be
only a feature writer like i will only
do features
or i will only work in network
television which is not even a thing
anymore right because there's so many
streaming services
but at the time it was so the way that i
have navigated
uh this bias is for me not to think of
myself
as just like i will only do prime time
television
or i will only do features that was
never really the way that i thought
about my career
when i transitioned from being a studio
and network executive to being a writer
one of the reasons why i did that is
because i wanted to have control
over the stories that i was putting out
into the world which i really didn't
as a network or studio executive right
so
when i made that transition i decided if
somebody wants to tell the story in
preschool animation
i will do it in preschool animation if
somebody wants to do this as an
mow meaning movie of the week for
homework hall of fame
which is how i did the alicia keys
project firelight
i will do it in television and for
hallmark hall of fame
you know so allowing myself the
uh the opportunities that go beyond
where you really
usually think of like where your story
should be told
um it's a way that i have been able to
navigate this bias
that i have gone from working on an nbc
show
to working on go diego go and that was a
preschool show on nickelodeon and
everybody said you cannot take that job
you cannot do that job because you will
never make it back
to network television and i thought to
myself
how do i say no to a show that is going
to have a latino lead
that is going to teach kids spanish and
the importance of science
like i literally could not see a
downside to that
and then i went from that to releasing
la mismaluna
which fox searched lightbot so a lot of
this for me was like
i can't worry about what people may
think because i'm working on preschool
tv or am i doing a
cable movie instead of a feature film i
just want to work
at the places that are willing to tell
my stories
and so instead of always thinking about
oh this story is never going to be able
to be told no i just go to the places
that are willing
to tell the kinds of stories that i want
to do
and that has helped me not go crazy
and not to think about the negative
aspects of what we do
but like i said earlier until the top
and the ceos at these companies
really try to create some sort of
mandate for what needs to happen
i'm not sure how much it's going to
change thank you for that
i think you've been a master at the
navigation obviously
i think i wonder does anybody else have
any any
comments i guess about gatekeeping
gatekeeping and gatekeepers and how
they've had to
what can i say can i do one more thing
do you mind if i just say one more thing
i think that the most powerful thing
that i have ever done in my career
is to have the courage to speak up
so a job was never worth me not speaking
up
and i think a lot of us because we are
the only ones in the room
whether it's a writer's room or we're
only in an executive
position or we're the only ones that are
getting like
the one latino movie done in the next
three to five years
that sometimes we're too afraid to say
something
and i think that one thing and you know
i'm old enough that maybe
that's why you guys have given me the
courage but i was like this when i was
in network television and i had to speak
up you know
we had a show taking place in miami and
there were no latinos not even in the
background
and i was like you can't do a show in
miami without any latinos not even on
the background like
there were there were positions that i
took
and continue to take
that i think are really important for
those of us who are working and for
those of us who are
able to develop and create programming
that our voices need to be heard
like one thing that i'm very clear about
when i go in
especially in children's programming
where a lot of times they're trying to
make everybody just
be like everybody else i always say a
character cannot be replaceable
or interchangeable if it's a character
of color
yes so i don't want you to just be able
to put anybody else in that role
and i know that there's a way and you
know some people do that
but for me but being able to say that
and then being clear it's like if you're
going to develop with me
this is the person that you're actually
going to get and you cannot assign me a
composer because you have been working
with that composer for the last
10 shows that you did you have to ask me
if i have an opinion about a composer of
color
that i might want to use instead of the
white composer that you have been using
for the last 20 years
like being able to empower yourself
as a as a creator of color and not allow
these things to continue because you're
afraid that your show is not going to
make it on the air
unless we speak up these things are
going to continue
so the way that i see it is even if i am
let's suppose that i'm fired
which hasn't happened that often by the
way but let's suppose that i have fire
i can promise you that that executive or
that producer is not
going to forget that conversation
and that might bring change to somebody
else
and another project that is not even
related to me because they're
always going to remember the outspoken
likia mexicana
that came in here and told us you cannot
do this
right and so i feel
strongly that those of us who are
working
must have the courage to speak up in
these situations
um thank you and um
if i might say i think also um
at this moment um i don't i'm one sort
of feels
exhausted by this process and um it's
time to stop asking nicely as though
we're asking for a favor
and try and change perception that what
we are doing
is just demanding what you have normal
rights you know
and not feel all the time that one is
that that one has to somehow persuade
people but rather that look at the
wider society that's not going to that
that will
accept that uh you know change things so
that people accept
that that what what what that the
present status quo
is inherently wrong and therefore it's
how are we going to put it right
not how are we going to have favors
dispensed
um our stories matter
you know black stories latina stories
indigenous stories
our stories matter our representation
matter our lives matter
and we need that to be you know inherent
not just in in in
in our industry but in in the wider
society because people need to
need to understand that the present
status quo
is unsustainable and it is very
difficult i agree with it
sometimes it's very difficult to uh
to speak out when you're a writer
and uh you know from my point of view
when you're getting notes which are just
some notes could be just sort of
horrendous and you're you think
you know if i say anything is it better
if i'm working at it from the inside and
all of that and you know at just some
point was exhausted with it
um and you know we just want to be we
we need to be heard and our stories need
to be heard and
uh and it's we can't do it alone without
the wider society accepting and
understanding that the
current status quo is unsustainable
and unacceptable yes lulu can you share
us a point of view on
navigating with this world with
gatekeepers and
and your talent um yeah i think
um you know one of the things i
tell so many filmmaker friends of mine
who are
um women of color is
you know we talk a lot about like do you
build your own table do you
try to get a seat at the table we have
these debates of like we just gotta
say forget the system and just build our
own table
but you know you have to have the
numbers you have to have power in order
to go and build a table and you know the
generations
that came before us they didn't have
that choice they had to
find a seat at the table and ask to be
let in
in order to build their clout their
you know whatever reputation all of it
in order to go and maybe
create their own table um
and so i i i think that for me
i i have to take this perspective of
abundance
where you know which is something that
we all have to unlearn
of not thinking of of ourselves as
special or singular and there's only
room for one
you know because as everyone comes up
that's how we you know have more power
create you know those are the people
that you can turn to and say well
um because when you're there alone it's
terrible you go i i it's like
you know you don't know if you're crazy
or they're crazy right because they're
convincing you that you're the one who's
crazy but if you have
other people around who have this other
perspective
um it's just better and so one of the
things i talk about with um
these friends is transparency where
anybody who asks me i'll show them my
contracts
um i ask friends of mine to show me
their contracts i think it's really
important
that we have comps um
with other filmmakers who have done a
first feature second future are doing
their first tv show going
well what did you make and what rights
were you
given were you allowed to pick your dp
were you allowed to pick
the writers in your room and you know um
i
so i always tell my friends not to get
overly excited when they get offered a
deal before you get excited
do your research talk to as many people
as possible who have worked with this
company
find out how they treat people of color
how they treat
um both financially and creatively
uh and um you know and that way they
are sort of armed with facts
to go back to their reps to say i'm not
gonna take this deal
i'm not gonna come to to the table and
be grateful
which is what they're expecting you know
and so i said don't stop getting excited
stop being grateful and make sure that
they're actually
valued about that they are actually
value about
valuing sorry i just had a brain um
they're actually giving uh you know as
much value
as you deserve and unfortunately
sometimes that means you have to say no
and that's something i talk a lot about
as well
is the power of saying no because
before i made the farewell i was just
saying yes to everyone because i was so
desperate to
make a story to make a film and and get
it out somehow
but it um there's such a like
emotional um deficit like there's a
payment that goes in nothing is for
free you know and so you might say yes
to somebody
and they turn your story into something
else
you're not properly paid to do this work
you can burn out so quickly and so i
think that
the importance of of um you know having
the confidence and the value in your own
work
to say you know i'm not gonna do this
work unless
the proper conditions are met because i
can't do my best work
if these conditions are not met and if i
can't do my best work
when the work comes out and people go
well look here's an asian woman and we
gave it a shot we did this film
in it but it failed you know it's gonna
be
put on you and so that's the first thing
i say to
anybody who works with me is like you
know if you
value what i do this these are the terms
in which i need
to do my best work including bringing my
own collaborators who may not have the
same credits
you know who you may not be as familiar
with um
but this is the organic process for me
and if i can't have my process
then you're not going to get the result
that you're looking for
thank you elemay i wanted to give you a
chance to to comment
uh before we have to move on to
questions
sure yeah i i i just i'm loving
listening to everybody
um i i really appreciate what lulu said
about
um this notion of abundance about about
thinking differently
about um about our stories about stories
that come from bipac communities about
stories that come from
voices that have been uh have been
marginalized or silenced or erased
within
within the film world um and
i really appreciate what she said about
about building a new process and about
considering
um who who who these gay gatekeepers are
um so when it came to the body remembers
when the world broke open
it's it's a film about two indigenous
women in east vancouver in canada
it covers issues of domestic violence
and um
it's it's a bit of a heavy film and we
had a really hard time
uh closing our financing gap and we had
a really hard time
finding a distributor um because people
continually said this the story is
important we understand it's an
important story but we don't know
how we're going to market it we don't
know how we're going to sell this story
um and we kept getting that same sort of
response and then
the film got in front of eva duvernay
and tylane jones at array
releasing um and they decided to pick up
the film and that changed everything for
us and i think
with that what that speaks to is the
fact that when there are people who come
from marginalized communities who come
from
uh who are bipark uh in these positions
of power people who are able to
to shift the narrative and to and to to
show that there is an audience
for films like for films like mine and
for the others on the panel
um it changes everything and so now that
film is available
on netflix to such a broad audience and
what we're finding is that
despite the fact that it's such a
specific story about two indigenous
women
it has so many universal themes and
there's so many people who are drawn to
the story on a personal level
who aren't indigenous who aren't from
canada um
and so it really is about shifting who
is in these positions of power it's
about um
making uh about holding gatekeepers
accountable
and and acknowledging that um as long as
there are you know
straight cisgendered white men in
positions of power
deciding who whose stories get told and
whose don't
um we're going to continue to see the
same uh
the same issues replicated and the same
voices being silenced so
i have i have so much gratitude for
people like ava
and tulane at array because they're just
opening
so many uh so many doors for for voices
like mine
and um and and i think i think that
that really speaks to um a brighter
future for all of us and i hope that
this moment that we're experiencing
right now in terms of
uh a reckoning with with race relations
in in the united states and also in
canada i hope that the work that's being
done right
now um continues into the future and i
really hope we see lasting change and
and lasting accountability well you know
what i also think it's important
for um artists who are not
a person of color for them to also
be thoughtful about the projects that
they take on
you know are they asking the question
when they are brought in to do a latino
story
have you met with latino writers
have you met with latino directors
you know that they themselves
also look at this journey as their
journey
as well and i think that everybody
should be able to tell the stories that
they want to tell so i have a different
opinion about you know
a a a person who may be passionate about
a story that they want to tell
i'm talking about dealing with these
gatekeepers at the studios
if you are being brought in to do a
story
that is not really your own are you
asking questions yourself so not just
ask asking those questions like it is so
sad for me to know that there are
two big latino movies that are going to
be released
this year and neither one is being
directed by a latino
you know and thank god that one of them
is directed by a person of color
but we are still having our stories told
by non-latinos and so
we have a responsibility to speak out
but i think hopefully
the community as a whole is also
speaking up about these
issues and saying who have you met
on this you know it's so interesting i i
think
four of the last six academy awards for
director
have been given to a mexican
but we still can't find directors
that can direct the movies that the
studios want to make
about us it's it's just the irony of it
is
it's incredible to me it's i love that
you're saying that it's
it's interesting because i'm i'm just
thinking
as a metaphor as an analogy like when we
travel
at least when i travel right or when i
go out to in la to a restaurant
i'm like oh i want to eat i'll eat let's
go to that vietnamese restaurant
it's full of vietnamese people like
that's a good sign
when it's filled with vietnamese people
right or wherever if you
you're traveling you you want to go to
the local places and you look to make
sure that the
you know not only the people cooking but
the people eating are actually from that
background
um and it gives it legitimacy and how do
we not do that with movies
you know what i mean like if i want to
see
a mexican film i want to make sure the
people
cooking the meal and the people who are
coming to the meal
are giving it the validation because
that's saying to me that that's
an authentic um experience
uh so you know and i i talk a lot with
friends about
my experience when i get notes from
people who
don't come from my background how do i
say it right like how do i say you don't
get this
because you don't get it because you're
not from where i'm from
and it took me a long time to actually
find those words because you still have
to be polite you can't just come
straight out and be like
hey if you don't let me do it that's
racist like you can't really say that
right to it
exactly so you know there's this
diplomatic way of saying
i really respect your opinion but i
don't think this is a story note i think
this is a cultural note
that you don't understand because you
don't come from where i come from
and they really respond well at least
producers that i've worked with really
respond well to that
but i think you're rightly i wish that
executives producers
people who are working with creators
that
are from different backgrounds don't
wait until they
say to you you know because that's a
scary
it's a lot to carry you know all of that
pressure
for them to come to you and say hey you
don't come from where i come from like
you should recognize that
and say that right up front and give
them the space
so that the creator can you know
point when something is a cree is a is a
cultural difference
and a perspective difference rather than
a purely like
technical craft note you know what i'm
saying
yeah and also you know like looking at
your film i was thinking about
when i watched it like sometimes even
though it is a cultural thing that like
people may not understand
sometimes it is in the specificity that
you find commonality
so i remember when i went to see your
film
that whole cemetery scene with
the crying and the food and it was like
is the other los muertos for us like it
is crazy
and you know uh i don't know if you guys
know this but coco
is the highest grossing pixar movie in
china
it i think it made 200 million dollars
in china
and i was like why i wonder why coco
made so much money in china right and
and sometimes it's like coco cannot be
more specific
it is so specifically mexican
but there's a whole group of people that
saw this movie
and found commonality in the specificity
of it
and sometimes you know what executives
are really afraid of
is the thing that they should fear the
least because people will find their way
through the movies they will have some
understanding the same thing happened
with under the same moon in jordan
where i was thinking how are people
going to relate to this
in jordan well they were experiencing a
huge amount
of people coming in from syria
and all of a sudden there was so much
commonality in that
and so i i would hope that also it's
something that they
that they look at that i i saw your
movie lulu and i immediately
like connected with so many of the
things even though we could not be more
far apart in terms of you know our
cultures or our backgrounds
thank you i loved your movie as well
um i i i was i was what i
mean i think one of the things that
exercises me is how do we stop this
being
our problem we have to overcome we have
how do we because actually the reality
is it is not
our problem it is the pro it's it's the
problem of the people around us and how
do we
make sure that the even the perspective
from which we look at what to be done
what has to be done isn't just focused
on us
having to be super women or or do this
and how do we overcome
but how do we change the conversation to
what are you doing i mean you you are
wrong
therefore how are how are we going to
make you
um how are we going to involve
you in the solution and not have it
about us having to overcome you
how do you make you part of the solution
and i think that's when we talk about
gatekeepers um i you know obviously
having um more
you know diverse i've used the word uh
gatekeepers is going to make a
difference
but there's also that it's all that
there is also the majority population
that they
have to be part of this um and
and we can do things like you know
making have the
mandating things as we discussed earlier
but there's also
somehow that hearts and minds have to be
changed i
i that's what sort of exercises me
because people also
have to be willing otherwise what
happens is that they'll make that
i remember being told to a filmmaker
here oh we already made a black film
you know they made one three years
before and you know so that's that
as opposed to thinking this is just
normal
this is normal life and this is just how
the world
when i step foot outside my door looks
like and this is what it should look
like
um here and i can understand that you
your stories are interesting to you
my stories are interesting to me let's
make them all that's what i'm that's
what exercises me
is how do we stop approaching this as
our
problem and look and and
focus on and also focus on how we can
change make make it a wider society or
wider
problem within the industry and not
something that we
have to overcome but that there should
not be that resistance in the first
place maybe in utopia but that's
that's what i think we should be driving
towards
um it's exhausting when you can i just
say when you go in and pitch
a story and the first half hour you're
not pitching your story you're not
pitching yourself
you're pitching your relevance and um
and i had a most
wonderful sort of experience of
pitching to a a an african-american
woman
executive and it was like suddenly it
was like having the weights on your feet
the the anvil that's been hold on your
feet
gone because i could suddenly just pitch
pitch my story pitch what it was
without the sort of preamble and it's
how do we get there where there isn't
that resistance in the first place
rather than
us having to always be so special in
order to be able to
to get through in canada we're kind of
in this unique position
and uh we've sort of modeled what's
happened in australia and new zealand
in terms of indigenous stories
indigenous representation
indigenous people are leading the
conversation and
and we're seeing that now in canada we
have the indigenous screen office
and a lot of work has been placed into
developing something called the pathways
and protocols document um and it's
literally
a guide for non-indigenous people
wanting to work with indigenous
communities wanting to tell stories with
indigenous content
and it's it's in a lot of ways it's it's
a way of holding
non-indigenous people accountable
because it's it's trendy right now to
tell
indigenous stories like every week i get
multiple
multiple emails multiple calls um
requesting that i you know i direct or
help write the story that has an
indigenous character or indigenous
whatever um and it's such an incredible
resource to have this pathways and
protocols document
to say here like look at this document
read it this is this is what you need to
do
and these are the questions you need to
ask yourself should you be telling the
story are you the right person to tell
this story
have you connected with communi
communities in in a responsible ethical
meaningful way um and if they haven't
you know they have that
they have that document to look to and
so
i think um we need to continue to
to move in that direction when it comes
to telling all stories that that are
relevant
uh or or represent bypoc communities or
lgtbq 2s communities or just you know
the disabled community i think there
needs to be
some sort of uh these mandated documents
in a way that that
that uh that serve us as a tool because
there's so much emotional labor so much
education that we have to do
as as as the other um when it comes to
telling our own stories and and having
that document having that tool has been
such a such a weight off my shoulders as
an indigenous storyteller and i think
it also protects our communities because
there's there's kind of this
um toxic form of extractive filmmaking
that has existed since
the cameras first started rolling so
people of color
indigenous people anybody who is who's
the other has been
fetishized or romanticized or
misrepresented in front of the camera
and there's just uh there's just so much
work to do to un to unlearn all of that
to change all of those ways of operating
um and when it comes to like i said this
extractive form of filmmaking
um it comes from people who are not from
those communities
going in with a voyeuristic lens and
getting it all wrong
every single time they always get it
wrong um and so
it needs to shift to us being the ones
telling the stories to us leading the
conversation
um and and like i said this this
pathways and protocols document has been
such
a lifesaver for me and i think a lot of
other indigenous
creatives i believe that we have to
uh wrap up i mean in order to ask a
couple of questions
and so i'm going to hand it off to sean
to
provide us with our questions uh lulu
bird dahia nissan elemaya what a
beautiful conversation and thank you for
being so transparent
the academy dialogues was created as a
platform to give our members
an opportunity to have truthful
transparent conversations
and i wanted to ask you what dialogue do
you hope this conversation will inspire
in others
we can start with you bird oh with
myself
well i think so many things that i feel
like
our panelists spoke about today was
really
i think about one about one
the the the distinctness that their
voices is lending
i think to the form you know uh the form
of storytelling the forms of
storytelling form of cinema but also
that
that there that there are audiences who
are hungry for it
you know but there's a disconnect
between the stories they're trying to
tell
and what the audience want wants you
know and i think that that is our
industry
and i think that our industry could be a
lot more bountiful and successful
if these voices were really supported
and
and really brought to the screens for
these hungry audiences to
experience and to to
share thank you lulu what dialogue do
you hope this conversation will inspire
in others
uh i think that around what we were
saying of putting the
pressure putting the um responsibility
on the gatekeepers themselves the
executives
um so that you know the writers the
directors
are not always the ones having the
conversation
ourselves to say how do we you know
better this situation
that hopefully the members will talk
more
and look at their own um position in the
industry
and their own power and say you know
what are the questions that i can do
better
what what also how do i better educate
myself
so i can participate and be part of the
solution
and amaya what about yourself
oh wow this has been such a rich
conversation and
um i think ultimately i
i hope viewers and and and academy
members especially
um walk away uh and take time to
consider
how uh we're all implicated in this
narrative how we move together
how we move forward together um and how
can we
dismantle these toxic systems of of
working
and how can we how can we build a new
way forward
how can we build models that are rooted
in equity
and and respect and accountability um
and
how can we build models of working that
are generative
and and consider a future that doesn't
necessarily
reflect our our present moment you know
where
um where we're having to have this kind
of conversation i really hope that in 10
years from now we're not having to have
the exact same conversations
nissan and lahia you both represent
um flexibility everyone does but you all
specifically because
nissan you came from being a doctor
before i hear you spoke about being an
executive
for new filmmakers that are coming up
how is how important is it
to be flexible with going after your
dreams and your passions
um i think um but you know from my point
of view it's less about being flexible
than about having uh you know confidence
that um what i what i often find i
sometimes mentor um beginning
writers of color and they they censor
themselves so much they go oh
am i ready can i do it you know there
are certain
and we all know that um that there are
people from the sort of the wider
community who've walked past a film set
and they're ready to direct a
marvel movie you know whereas as a woman
and as a woman of color you'll say oh am
i ready so it's less about being
flexible than about saying yes i
you know just you know having a go and
from the other side
it's about not having everything on the
shoulders of one
black filmmaker so that if that black
filmmaker has a go
and it isn't perfect you it that that
there isn't any bigger conversation
about oh well we've done our black
and it was a disaster we're not going to
do it again or making you know each
person representative of
everything as opposed to just them just
trying to make their film so
i think that's what i hope will people
will take away from this
that we have um sort of rich stories to
tell that we're an asset
we're not a problem to be solved we're
an asset
and that um we should be allowed to to
to
to to try and allow to you know to
participate without
you know the huge amount of pressure
that can be honor somebody
and and that we while we should be
flexible
we should also ourselves uh you know
just
be more um you know not not
self-censored
all the time and feel that you know i
just need to be
worried about the the consequences and
those consequences should not be
disproportionate
to uh you know making a film it works it
works it doesn't work it doesn't have to
be everything so that
um the pressure becomes too difficult
thank you so much
did you want to add to that sure so um i
heard a quote once that
said a nation is only as great as
its dreams and dreams
are dreamt by artists
now i have no idea who originally said
that i heard that from tom cruise
[Laughter]
on the actor's studio and it has stuck
with me
since that interview so what i would say
to that
new generation of filmmakers writers
artists is especially in the world that
we're living in
your voices and your stories are
vital to our survivor to ours
to our serve yeah to our survival to our
survival
the second thing i would say though is i
heard a statistic that
less than 50 of americans actually have
a passport
which i think is a disgrace and even a
much
much much lesser percentage of them
speak a second language
so when you think about the most
powerful country in the world
delivering the most powerful content
to the world and
less than 50 percent of us have actually
traveled
our stories become
so much more vital because
it is sometimes the only window
that the audience in this country has
about the outside world and if you want
to know why this country is where it is
is because people don't leave this
country
they're not experiencing what is
happening in the world
so just imagine how important our
stories
and our point of view is
in trying to change the perception
of who we are in the world
and who the world is and that's why i
think it's so important
that our stories are told and heard and
considered
thank you so much for that beautiful
answer bird lulu
nissan and alemaya thank you so much for
your time and for participating in
academy dialogues
and on behalf of the entire academy
thank you so much
thank you for having us thank you thank
you very much